virginie ledoyen et axelle laffont je
n'avais plus comme une marche très bien
on a les derniers voulaient ya des
chiffres qui tombent tous les quarts
d'heure autant télévision en radio en
cinéma en interne est partout même je
vous le dis dans la dans le milieu de
l'automobile at on accepte ça marche
bien à combien on est content à combien
on est content on est content si on est
très très content si j'allais à 500
milles sur 500 m c'est non c'est énorme
c'est ensemble est-ce qu'on fasse en
somme ils ont fait quoi on se marine
ouais ouais
[Musique]
un vrai mariage je bloque la rue et tout
sur ses plaies c'était à 500000 je le
fais moi je le fais vraiment mais moi
aussi
[Applaudissements]
vous auriez pu trouver autre chose pour
mes péchés mais c'est mal c'est malin ça
passe sa mort mais à trop en plus et
c'est nouveau ça c'est très sympa bcsa
voilà